السلام عليكم ورحمه الله من الجزيره اقدم
لكم موجز الانباء عاشت فرنسا على وقع يوم
احتجاجي عاشر نظمته النقابات ضد قانون رفع
سن التقاعد من اثنين وستين الى 64 عاما
ارتسعت رقعه التظاهر لتشمل مدنا على راسها
باريس وليون جنوبي البلاد وتخللتها صدمات
واعتقالات ودعت الحكومه الاحزاب والقوى
السياسيه الى ادانه العنف وحثه النقابات
على الحوار مجددا الاسبوع القادم غير ان
اتحاد النقابات العمل دعا الى احتجاجات
جديده في السادس من ابريل
ذكرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها اختبرت
بنجاح صاروخ كروز فرط صوتي من طرازي
موسكيت مضادا للسفن في بحر اليابان
واوضحت ان المقذوفه تمكنا من ضرب هدف وهمي
هذا وصلت حامله طائرات امريكيه مجهزه
بمفاعلين نوويين للمشاركه في مناورات مع
كوريا الجنوبيه في المقابل اللي اختبر
زعيم كوريا الشماليه خطط عمليات شن هجوم
النووي
ودعا لانتاج مزيد من المواد النوويه لصنع
الاسلحه
من جهته قلا منسقه الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي
ان بلاده مستمره في التاكد من ان لديها
القدرات العسكريه المناسبه للردع اذا لزم
الامر لحمايه مصالحها ومصالح حلفائها في
منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
تتاهب اوكرانيا لما تسميه هجوم الربيع
المضاد مع وصول اولى الدبابات الغربيه
الثقيله حيث اكد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
على الدور الحاسم الذي قد تلعبه هذه
الدبابات في استعاده كيف المدن التي تسيطر
عليها روسيا بينما شدد الكرملين التي الذي
سبق ان اكد ان موسكو ستستهدف هذه الدبابات
لحظه دخولها ساحه المعركه شدد على ان
الخطوه تعتبر تصعيدا من الدول الغربيه
لانخراطها في الحرب في الاثناء اكدت
واشنطن ان الافق الوحيده للتسويه هو
باستعاده اوكرانيا لاراضها
اعلنت احزاب المعارضه في اسرائيل انتهاء
الاجتماعي الاول الذي عقد في منزل الرئيس
اسحاق واكد الاحزاب انها ستبذل قصرها
جهدها لانجاح ما سمته المهمه الوطنيه
المتمثله في الحفاظ على الديمقراطيه ووحده
الشعب وفي سياق تعليقه على اعلان وزير
الامن القومي تمر بن جفير اتفاقه مع
نتنياهو على التصديق على انشاء الحرس
الوطني قال زعيم المعارضه انه من الافضل
ان لا يؤسس حرس وطني تحت امراه
ياهو بتقديم وعود يدرك انه لن ينفذها ووصف
الخطوه بالجنونيه انتهى الموجه لما كنتم
طبت اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]